my photos ladies outgoing president
Planned Parenthood Cecile Richards her
new memoir reservoirs called making
trouble standing up speaking out and
finding the courage to lead guess what
you don't need courage to lead just ask
Paul Ryan Cecile Richards everybody
welcome today is officially your last
day as president of Planned Parenthood
after twelve years twelve years that's
right did you find Jesus
if so welcome to the flock I've been so
honored to do this job for 12 years
Planned Parenthood is actually one of
the most popular organizations in the
country even according to Fox News and
one in five women in this country you've
been to us for health care and I'm so
proud of what we've done and I'm ready
to make room for somebody else to lead
the organization now now you claim that
Planned Parenthood is not in the federal
budget that's exactly correct but then
why am I so mad about the federal budget
funding Planned Parenthood and abortions
yes so I don't know why you're mad but I
need an answer I'm furious so Planned
Parenthood operates like all other
health care providers in the country we
get reimbursed for preventive services
like birth control which is very popular
in America we do pap smears we do breast
exams and all of that is reimbursed just
like hospitals federal funding does not
pay for abortion except in very limited
circumstances so we operate like
everyone else no I heard it it is paid
for by the federal tonight my uncle
cells sends out this this tweet and he
has it also has an email with a bunch of
information and pictures on it right and
that's been going around for years right
well in fact he's he's wrong and so is a
lot of Congress and that's why actually
there's been such an outpouring of
support around the country especially
among women when this president and this
Congress tried to you know defund as
they said or prevent women from coming
to Planned Parenthood we were able to
beat back the efforts to both defund
Planned Parenthood and repeal Obamacare
and planned parents are still open all
across the United States of America you
had a meeting with Jovanka Jared and
Ivanka in 2017 that's correct in this
book you talk a little bit about that
they made you a very good offer you and
Planned Parenthood what happened well so
Ivanka Trump had said she wanted to meet
to talk about Planned Parenthood because
her father had said he was going to
defund us again and I thought well if
there was any chance to make my case I
you know wanted to do that I did make my
husband come with me so that I have a
witness but actually really they they
didn't want to talk too much about
Planned Parenthood pretty much Jared
Kushner said if we would quit providing
access to safe and legal abortion which
we will not then he would actually get
more federal funding for Planned
Parenthood and I just said look we're
not going to trade off women's rights in
this country
for money that's just not
it sounds like a a deal you got to give
a little to take a little well we're not
making deals about women's health and
women's rights and and and and actually
Ivanka did say she said well you have to
understand my father's pro-life I said
well he can have his own opinion but he
can't take away the rights of millions
of American women to make their own
decisions about their pregnancy and how
can he say he's pro-life when he's
trying to deport dreamers take away
health care for millions of people in
this country and maternity benefits all
the things that this administration is
trying to do so I just feel like he
really needs to rethink what his values
are well he's very Pro Hitler you've
said that if members of Congress could
get pregnant a lot of issues would be
solved don't you think well but I I have
an issue with that how our old white men
over the age of 50 going to get pregnant
exactly exactly makes any sense like yes
no I think that's exactly right in fact
I remember when one of the senators said
that he thought we shouldn't even be
coming covering maternity benefits for
women because he was never going to need
them so I guess apparently he was passed
his childbearing years and but thank
this is why we need more women in office
debbie Stabenow the senator from
Michigan said well I bet your mother did
and actually we were able to get
maternity benefits for millions of women
but this administration is trying to
take them away are you just inciting
violence here make trouble what are you
getting at I think it's important I look
at this pit this feels like just and
tear all of this having your attitude so
angry it's a you know right after the
election every day it seemed like
someone stopping on the street and said
what could I do I need to do something
more and I decided instead of talking to
every single person on the subway as
some people try to do I'll do that yeah
I'm going to do that that I would put it
in a book instead and I hope it's kind
of a call to action and a little bit of
a memoir and what I have seen around the
country is that women are doing
everything they're you know they're
marching they're going to town hall
meetings they're calling the members of
Congress but we got a really
sure is that this November they're going
to vote because that's how we're going
to change the direction from there all
those women out there
I hear voting in December as much cooler
tell me something I already know well I
think it's maybe I just something you
you need to know is that Planned
Parenthood actually now has twice the
membership of the National Rifle
Association
I just birth control and planned parent
it are really popular so maybe you
should switch your allegiances that's my
idea those numbers can't be right
it's absolutely happy right absolutely
all those numbers are right there right
there correct her new memoir is called
making trouble Cecile Richards the fight
continued
[Music]